Doctor Sean Roden normally works for NASA caring for astronauts before and during their missions, which he does from Houston Mission Control. But back in 2012, he had another gig as the doctor at the Amundsen-Scott Station at the South Pole. When he got there, they told him this story.
肖恩·罗登医生通常为美国国家航空航天局（NASA）工作，在休斯顿任务控制中心为宇航员提供任务前后的医疗保障。但在2012年，他在南极阿蒙森-斯科特站担任医生，还有过另一份工作。当他到达那里时，他们告诉了他这个故事。
I think it was probably the station manager. It's the story that's told.
我想这很可能是那个站长告诉他的。这是一个流传甚广的故事。
Is this the first story they tell every doctor who gets this job?
这是他们告诉每一位担任该职位的医生的第一个故事吗？
Pretty much.
差不多吧。
They tell doctors this story because it is the most spectacular thing anyone has ever done in this kind of job. The story goes like this. In 1961, a Russian doctor got appendicitis at a Soviet Antarctic station, and so he needed emergency surgery to remove his appendix or he would probably die.
他们告诉医生这个故事，是因为它是此类工作中发生过的最壮观的事情。故事是这样的：1961年，一名俄罗斯医生在苏联南极科考站患上阑尾炎，他需要进行紧急手术切除阑尾，否则很可能会丧命。
And he was the one doctor there, snowed in during a blizzard. And so he had to figure out what to do. And so this Russian, a 27-year-old surgeon named Leonid Rogozov removed his own appendix and lived.
当时他是那里唯一的医生，大雪封山，正值暴风雪期间。所以他必须想办法。这个27岁的俄罗斯外科医生列昂尼德·罗戈佐夫切除了自己的阑尾，并活了下来。
Could you perform this procedure on yourself?
你能给自己做这个手术吗？
Oh, hell, no. [LAUGHS] I guess if my life depended on it, I'd rather die trying than give up.
哦，见鬼，当然不。 [笑] 我想如果生命受到威胁，我宁愿尝试失败而死，也不愿放弃。
Dr. Roden isn't a surgeon, though. And so to try to understand just how difficult this would be, I turned to a surgeon and associate professor at the Harvard Medical School named Doug Smink, who hadn't heard this story. But he's written a lot about appendectomies for textbooks and medical journals, and he's performed the procedure a lot.
不过罗登医生不是外科医生。为了理解这有多困难，我请教了哈佛医学院的外科医生兼副教授道格·斯明克，他之前没听说过这个故事。但他为教科书和医学期刊写过很多关于阑尾切除术的文章，并且做过很多次这种手术。
Probably 200 to 300 times, at least, maybe more.
可能至少有200到300次，甚至更多。
We have two accounts of this. There's a published report that the doctor wrote up in the Soviet Antarctic Expedition Information Bulletin. And then we have his--
我们有两个关于这件事的记录。一个是医生发表在《苏联南极考察信息公报》上的文章。另一个是他的——
I don't read that.
我不看那个。
[IRA LAUGHS]
[艾拉笑]
And we have the patient's diary.
还有病人的日记。
Are you calling him the patient or the surgeon? You could call him either one, right?
你是称他为病人还是外科医生？你可以两者都叫，对吧？
Well, it's interesting because in his account, he goes back and forth between those things over and over again.
很有意思，因为在他的叙述中，他一直在两者之间反复转换。
That's fascinating.
太迷人了。
So this is from his published account. He says, "the symptoms noted were weakness, general malaise, later nausea. Body temperature rose to 37 degrees centigrade," which is 99 Fahrenheit. And then he wrote in his diary, April 30, 1961, "I did not sleep at all last night. It hurts like the devil. A snow storm whipping through my soul, wailing like 100 jackals."
这是摘自他公开发表的叙述。他说：“观察到的症状是虚弱、全身不适，随后出现恶心。体温升至37摄氏度，”即华氏99度。然后他在1961年4月30日的日记中写道：“昨晚我根本没睡。痛得要命。暴风雪在我的灵魂中肆虐，像100只豺狼一样哀号。”
Sounds like appendicitis.
听起来确实是阑尾炎。
Dr. Roden, the doctor who performed medicine at the South Pole went a little further.
在南极行医的罗登医生对此有更深的体会。
It sounds like a Russian. My wife and I have lived in Russia for over four years, off and on, with the space program and both speak Russian. So it's just-- it's poetic. It's perfect Russian.
听起来很俄罗斯。我和妻子因太空计划在俄罗斯断断续续生活了四年多，我们都会说俄语。所以这只是……很诗意。这是完美的俄语。
This is from the diary. "An oppressive feeling of foreboding hangs over me. This is it. I have to think through the only possible way out, to operate on myself. It's almost impossible, but I can't just fold my arms and give up."
这是日记里的内容：“一种压抑的不祥预感笼罩着我。就是这样了。我必须想出唯一的出路，给自己做手术。这几乎是不可能的，但我不能就此束手待毙。”
And then, later that same day at 6:30 at night, "The guys have found out. They keep coming by to calm me down. And I'm upset with myself. I've spoiled everyone's holiday. Tomorrow's May Day and everybody is running around preparing the autoclave. We have to sterilize the bedding because we're going to operate."
那天晚上6点半，他写道：“同事们发现了。他们一直过来安慰我。我对自己感到懊恼。我破坏了大家的节日。明天是五一劳动节，大家都在忙着准备高压灭菌器。我们必须对被褥进行消毒，因为我们要进行手术了。”
And then he explains which person is going to do what. A meteorologist is going to hold retractors, a driver is going to hold a mirror, and then, just in case one of those two guys who's never witnessed an operation passes out, another guy was on standby to jump in. "In the event that the patient lost consciousness"-- he switches to third person and refers to himself as the patient, "they were instructed to inject the drugs in the syringes that I had prepared and to administer artificial respiration."
然后他解释了每个人将要做什么。一名气象学家负责持拉钩，一名司机负责拿镜子，以防这两个从未见过手术的人晕倒，还有一个人随时准备顶上。“如果病人失去知觉，”他切换到第三人称，把自己称为病人，“他们被指示注射我准备好的注射器里的药物，并进行人工呼吸。”
Oh, geez.
天哪。
He writes, "The position of the patient at operation was designed to make it possible for him to perform the operation with minimal use of the mirror." And to do that, basically, they'd prop him up on his back.
他写道：“手术中病人的姿势设计是为了让他能够以最少使用镜子的方式进行手术。”为了做到这一点，他们基本上把他撑在背上。
Right.
没错。
He's leaning on one hip.
他侧身靠在一个髋部上。
Well, I'm just looking down at my own abdomen and trying to figure out how-- I know where I would make an incision. But to then see deeper down in the deeper layers would be a challenge. I'm sure that's where the mirror came in. It probably was also just really uncomfortable to sit in that position for two hours and try to work. I can only imagine.
我在低头看着自己的腹部，想弄明白……我知道我会在哪里做切口。但要看到更深层的组织将是一个挑战。我相信这就是镜子派上用场的地方。在那个姿势下坐两个小时并尝试工作肯定也非常不舒服。我只能想象。
I'm going to read from the diary. "My poor assistants. At the last minute, I looked over at them. They stood there in their surgical whites, whiter than white themselves. I was scared, too. When I picked up the needle with the Novocain and gave myself the first injection, somehow I automatically switched into operating mode and from that point on, I didn't notice anything else."
我要读一下日记：“我可怜的助手们。最后一刻，我看着他们。他们穿着手术白衣站在那里，比白色还要白。我也很害怕。当我拿起装有普鲁卡因的针头给自己做第一次注射时，不知何故，我自动切换到了手术模式，从那时起，我什么也没注意到。”
Wow. That's amazing. Almost like an out-of-body experience, it sounds like he had.
哇。太神奇了。听起来他几乎有了一种灵魂出窍的体验。
"I worked without gloves. It was hard to see. The mirror helps, but it also hinders. After all, it's showing things backwards. I work mainly by touch. The bleeding is quite heavy, but I take my time. I try to work surely."
“我不戴手套工作。很难看清。镜子有帮助，但也有阻碍。毕竟，它显示的是反向的。我主要靠触觉工作。出血相当严重，但我从容不迫。我试图稳扎稳打。”
The other thing to remember in this is that not only is he just operating on himself, but he is quite ill. Patients who have appendicitis don't feel like doing anything. They just want to curl up in bed and hope somebody will make them better. So to actually have to function and think clearly, both function physically and mentally, is amazing. It's just amazing.
记住这一点，他不仅是在给自己做手术，而且他还病得很重。患有阑尾炎的病人什么都不想做。他们只想蜷缩在床上，希望有人能让他们好起来。所以还能正常运作和清晰思考，无论是身体还是心理，这都太惊人了。简直不可思议。
In fact, Rogozov spends most of the two-hour operation fighting off unconsciousness. After just 30 or 40 minutes, he wrote, he started to experience vertigo. Every four or five minutes he had to stop and rest. Dr. Smink explained to me that what happens in an appendectomy is you cut through the skin, then through a layer of fat, then three layers of muscle, then a layer of something called fascia. And then, finally, there's the peritoneum.
事实上，罗戈佐夫在两个小时的手术中大部分时间都在对抗昏迷。他说，仅仅30到40分钟后，他就开始感到眩晕。每四五分钟，他就得停下来休息一下。斯明克医生向我解释说，阑尾切除术的过程是切开皮肤，穿过一层脂肪，然后是三层肌肉，接着是一层叫筋膜的组织。最后，是腹膜。
I describe it like a clear balloon. It's about that thin.
我把它比作一个透明的气球。大约就那么薄。
Inside that balloon are the intestines. And you kind of poke around the intestines with your fingers to find the appendix.
那个气球里面是肠子。你得用手指在肠子周围摸索，找到阑尾。
The appendix is about the size of your pinky.
阑尾大约只有小指那么大。
And so he's having to move his own intestines out of the way to find the appendix.
所以他得把自己的肠子挪开才能找到阑尾。
Exactly. By feel, which is actually how we do it, often, in an open appendectomy. So he would have had experience with that. You basically feel around and you can feel what feels like a firm, almost like a sausage or something like that. And that is the appendix.
没错。靠感觉，实际上我们在开腹阑尾切除术中经常这样做。所以他肯定有过这方面的经验。你基本上就是四处摸索，你能感觉到摸起来像坚硬的东西，有点像香肠之类的。那就是阑尾。
But before Rogozov locates the appendix, he realizes that he accidentally tore into a part of the large intestine called the cecum and he has to sew it up. He wrote in his diary, "Suddenly it flashed in my mind there are more injuries here and I didn't notice them. I grew weaker and weaker.
但在找到阑尾之前，罗戈佐夫意识到他不小心刺破了一部分大肠（盲肠），他必须把它缝好。他在日记中写道：“突然间，我的脑海里闪过一个念头，这里有更多的伤口，而我没注意到。我越来越虚弱。”
My head starts to spin. Finally, here it is, the cursed appendage. With horror, I notice the dark stain at its base. That means just a day longer and it would've burst."
“我的头开始晕了。终于，它在这里，那该死的阑尾。我惊恐地注意到它根部的深色污渍。这意味着再过一天，它就会破裂了。”
And then, Rogozov doesn't write what is obvious to him-- that a burst appendix, he probably would have died.
罗戈佐夫没有写出显而易见的事实——如果阑尾破裂，他可能会死。
Yeah. I think he would have. I think he would have.
是的。我想他确实会死。我觉得他会。
Rogozov writes, "At the worst moment of removing the appendix, I flagged. My heart seized up. I noticeably slowed. My hands felt like rubber. Well, I thought, it's going to end badly." Then Rogozov doesn't say this explicitly, but Dr. Smink explained to me, in order to cut the appendix out, Rogozov would have pulled it out of his body with the stuff that it's attached to, like through the four-inch hole in his belly, and then he would have cut it off. Which of course, he did successfully. Fully recovered in two weeks, then back on the job.
罗戈佐夫写道：“切除阑尾最糟糕的时刻，我瘫软了。心脏骤停。我明显放慢了速度。我的手感觉像橡皮一样。好吧，我想，这要糟糕地收场了。”罗戈佐夫没有明确说，但斯明克医生向我解释，为了切除阑尾，罗戈佐夫不得不连同连接的组织一起把它从体内拉出来，穿过腹部那个四英寸的洞，然后切断它。当然，他成功做到了。两周后完全康复，然后回到岗位。
What's the most impressive part of this to you?
你认为这其中最令人印象深刻的部分是什么？
There are so many parts that are impressive to me. Probably most impressive to me, though, is what is the mental aspect of this. And he obviously had the perfect personality to pull this off. And then to have the courage, but also the wherewithal to assemble a team and explain to them what they were going to do while he had appendicitis.
对我来说有很多令人印象深刻的部分。可能最令我印象深刻的是心理层面。他显然拥有完美的性格来完成这件事。不仅有勇气，还有组建团队并向他们解释要做什么的能力，同时他还患着阑尾炎。
That's the thing. When I read this, I can't tell, well, could most surgeons do this or was he special?
就是这样。当我读到这些时，我无法判断这是否是大多数外科医生都能做到的，还是他很特别。
I think many people would be really uncomfortable doing it on themselves or would not be able to remain composed while also the patient.
我认为很多人在给自己做手术时会感到非常不舒服，或者在身为病人的同时无法保持镇定。
Could you do this?
你能做到吗？
Well, as we were talking, I was trying to think if I could. I don't know. I think you would never know until you were put in that situation. I'd like to think I could, if given no other option.
嗯，正如我们谈到的，我一直在想我是否能做到。我不知道。我想除非你身处那种境地，否则你永远不会知道。如果没别的选择，我希望自己能做到。
Of course, we all would like to believe that we would measure up if we were tested like this at something. Today on our program, we have two stories of people who put themselves into the kinds of situations where they are tested, doing things that are dangerous sometimes, doing the kinds of things where most of us would say, let somebody else do that one. But these people just had to take it on themselves. They do it themselves.
当然，如果面临这种考验，我们都希望相信自己能够胜任。今天我们的节目里有两个关于人们如何把自己置于经受考验的境地，做一些有时很危险的事情，做一些我们大多数人会说“让别人去干吧”的事情。但这些人却不得不自己承担起来。他们自己做。
Act 1 of our show is about somebody who decides to protect the border. Act 2 is about somebody who decides to run guns over a border. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们节目的第一幕是关于一个决定保护边界的人。第二幕是关于一个决定跨境走私枪支的人。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, "Line in the Sand." After he got out of college, Francisco Cantu decided that he wanted to become a Border Patrol agent, which his family did not understand at all. But he had his reasons for stepping up. And he did the job for four years and ended up writing about the experience.
第一幕，“沙线”。大学毕业后，弗朗西斯科·坎图决定成为一名边境巡逻队员，他的家人完全无法理解。但他有自己的理由。他干了四年，最终记录下了这段经历。
And his account was interesting to me and a bunch of us here at the radio show because he takes you inside in this way that does not seem to fit the usual ways that people talk about the border. It kind of sidesteps all the usual politics of the border. He's just documenting things. A lot of it is just random stuff that happened and that he saw while patrolling the border and during his training. Here he is.
他的叙述引起了我这儿电台的一群人的兴趣，因为他带你深入了解的方式似乎与人们通常谈论边境的方式不符。它巧妙地避开了所有常见的边境政治，他只是记录事实。很多事情只是他在巡逻边境和训练期间看到的随机事件。这就是他。
Robles ordered us from the mat room into the spinning room and we each took our place atop a stationary bicycle. At the front of the room, Robles climbed atop a machine that had been situated to face us and shouted for us to begin pedaling. At no point should your legs stop moving, he yelled.
罗布莱斯命令我们从垫子室到旋转室，我们每人坐上一辆固定自行车。在房间的前面，罗布莱斯爬上一台面对我们的机器，大喊让我们开始踩踏。他大喊：“任何时候你的腿都不能停下。”
When I say stand, lift your ass off the seat and keep it in the air until I tell you to sit. He snapped his head towards a stout man in the front row named Hanson. Is that clear, Mr. Hanson? Yes, sir, Hanson shouted, already out of breath.
“我说站起来时，把屁股从座位上抬起来，一直保持在空中，直到我叫你坐下。”他迅速扭头看向前排一个叫汉森的壮实男人。“清楚了吗，汉森先生？”“清楚了，长官！”汉森大声喊道，已经气喘吁吁。
As the minutes passed, Robles prodded us to work harder. Sit, he shouted, move those legs, stand. Your body is a tool, he announced, the most important one you have. A baton is nothing, a taser is nothing. Even your gun is nothing if you give up on your body when it becomes tired. If you can't hold it together when every muscle cries out for you to quit.
随着时间流逝，罗布莱斯不断催促我们更加努力。“坐下！”他大喊，“挪动那些腿！站起来！”他宣布：“你的身体是一个工具，你是拥有的最重要的一个。警棍什么也不是，泰瑟枪什么也不是。如果你在疲惫时放弃你的身体，甚至你的枪也什么也不是。如果你在每一块肌肉都在求你放弃时无法坚持下去。”
In the Border Patrol, Robles continued, you will be tested, I can promise you that. In my time, I have taken a life and I've saved a life. When I was brand new to the field, like all of you will be, my journeymen and I jumped a group of Salvadorians in the lettuce fields outside Yuma.
罗布莱斯继续说道：“在边境巡逻队，你会受到考验，我保证。在我的任期内，我夺走过生命，也拯救过生命。当我还是新手时，像你们所有人一样，我和我的同僚在尤马郊外的莴苣田里突袭了一群萨尔瓦多人。”
A man ran from us and I chased after him until I thought my legs would give out. I stumbled and tripped over dirt berms and rows of lettuce, but I kept chasing him until we came to the edge of the canal and the man turned to face me. He came at me before I could react and we went to the ground fighting.
“一个人从我们身边跑开，我追着他跑，直到我认为我的腿都要断了。我跌跌撞撞地越过土堆和莴苣行，但我一直追着他，直到我们来到运河边，那人转身面对我。在我反应过来之前，他就冲向我，我们扭打着倒在地上。”
If I'd given up, maybe the man would have killed me, but I didn't. I grappled with him in the dirt until I kicked him over the edge of the canal into the water. The man couldn't swim. None of them can. And so an hour later, me and my journeyman fished his dead body out of the water at a buoy line.
“如果我放弃了，也许那个人会杀了我，但我没有。我在泥土里和他搏斗，直到我把他踢下运河掉进水里。那个人不会游泳。他们都不会。所以一个小时后，我和我的同僚在浮标线处打捞出了他的尸体。”
Robles's eyes seemed to detach from his surroundings, like his gaze had turned inward. A year after that, he continued, I chased another man to the banks of the Colorado River. He ran out into the water and was swept away by the current like it was nothing. And I'll tell you what I did.
罗布莱斯的眼神似乎从周围环境中脱离出来，好像他的目光转向了内心。“一年后，”他继续说，“我追赶另一个人到科罗拉多河岸。他跑进水里，被电流像冲走虚无一样带走了。我告诉你们我做了什么。”
I battled to keep him afloat, even as I inhaled mouthfuls of water, even though I can't remember ever having been more tired. I save that man's life. And still, there's not a single day I don't think about the one I took before it.
“我拼命让他浮在水面上，尽管我吸入了一大口水，尽管我不记得曾经比这更累过。我救了那个人一命。然而，至今没有一天我不去想我之前夺走的那条生命。”
As Robles fell silent, we stood sweating over our bikes, our legs pedaling weakly. In the front row, I saw Hanson's head dip, his ass falling to the seat. Robles snapped his gaze from the middle of the room and turned his head towards Hanson. Get back up there, he roared. Don't give up on me, Mr. Hanson. Do not give up.
当罗布莱斯沉默时，我们汗流浃背地站在自行车上，双腿无力地踩踏着。在前排，我看到汉森的头垂了下来，屁股落在了座位上。罗布莱斯猛地从房间中间转移视线，转向汉森。“站起来！”他咆哮道。“别放弃，汉森先生。别放弃。”
As the sound of our labored breathing settled back over the room, I thought briefly of the man from El Salvador and I wondered how the news of his death might have arrived to his family. I watched Robles standing tall over his bicycle at the front of the room, dripping sweat. I wondered if he thought of his body as a tool for destruction or as one for keeping people safe. I wondered about my body, about what sort of tool it was becoming.
当房间里再次响起我们沉重的呼吸声时，我短暂地想到了那个来自萨尔瓦多的人，我想知道他死亡的消息是如何传到他家人那里的。我看着罗布莱斯站在房间前高大的自行车旁，汗水滴落。我想知道他是否认为自己的身体是毁灭的工具，还是保护人们安全的工具。我想知道我的身体，我想知道它正在变成什么样的工具。
My mother flew in from Arizona to see me for Christmas. She picked me up from the Academy on Christmas Eve and we drove up into the Evergreen Mountains of southern New Mexico. We stayed the night in a cabin and stayed up late, laughing, until the conversation finally descended into a discussion of my impending work.
我母亲从亚利桑那州飞来看我过圣诞节。她在平安夜把我从学院接走，我们开车前往新墨西哥州南部的常青树山脉。我们在一间小屋里过夜，聊到很晚，直到谈话最终变成对我即将从事工作的讨论。
Listen, my mother said, I spent most of my career as a park ranger, so I've got nothing against you working for the government. But don't you think it's sort of below you, earning a degree just to become a border cop? I don't really understand what you want from this work.
“听着，”我母亲说，“我的大部分职业生涯都是护林员，所以我对你为政府工作没什么意见。但你不觉得这有点屈才吗？拿个学位就为了当个边境警察？我真的不明白你想要这份工作做什么。”
I took a deep breath. Look, I told her, I spent four years in college studying the border. I'm tired of reading about it. I want to be on the ground, out in the field. I want to see the realities of the border, day in and day out. I don't see any better way to truly understand the place.
我深吸了一口气。“看，”我告诉她，“我在大学花了四年时间研究边境。我厌倦了阅读关于它的内容。我想身临其境，在实地工作。我想日复一日地看到边境的现实。我没看到有比这更好的方式来真正了解这个地方了。”
My mother stared at me. Are you crazy? She asked. There are 100 other ways of knowing a place. You grew up near the border. It's in our blood, for Christ's sake. Your great-grandparents brought my father across the border from Mexico when he was just a little boy. I kept my maiden name and passed it on to you so that you'd always carry that heritage.
我母亲盯着我。“你疯了吗？”她问。“有100种其他方式了解一个地方。你在边境附近长大。天哪，它就在我们的血液里。你的曾祖父母在祖父还是个小男孩时就把他带过了边境。我保留了我的娘家姓并传给你，这样你就能一直传承这份遗产。”
I lowered my voice. I'm grateful for those things, I told her, but having a name isn't the same as understanding a place. Do you remember, I asked my mother, how you joined the Park Service because you wanted to be outdoors? Because you felt you could understand yourself in wild places?
我压低声音。“我很感激这些，”我告诉她，“但拥有一个姓氏并不等于了解一个地方。你还记得吗，”我问母亲，“你加入公园管理局是因为你想在户外工作吗？因为你觉得你在野外可以了解自己？”
It's not that different, I said. There's something here I can't look away from. Maybe it's the desert, maybe it's the closeness of life and death, maybe it's the tension between the two cultures we carry. Whatever it is, I'll never understand it unless I'm close to it.
“这没什么不同，”我说。“这里有一些我无法移开视线的东西。也许是沙漠，也许是生死相依，也许是我们肩负的两种文化之间的张力。不管是什么，除非我靠近它，否则我永远无法理解。”
My mother shook her head. There are ways to learn these things that don't put you at risk. You make it sound like you'll be communing with nature and having heartfelt conversations all day. The Border Patrol isn't the Park Service. It's a paramilitary police force.
我母亲摇了摇头。“学习这些事情的方法有很多，不必让你自己处于危险之中。你说得好像你会整天与自然交流，进行衷心的交谈。边境巡逻队不是公园管理局。它是一支准军事警察部队。”
Listen, I said, I know you don't want your only son turning into a heartless cop. I know you're afraid the job will turn me into someone brutal and callous. But that's not me. And those aren't the kind of people that I see at the Academy. Nearly half my classmates are Hispanic. Some of them grew up right on the border.
“听着，”我说，“我知道你不想让你唯一的儿子变成冷酷的警察。我知道你害怕这份工作会让我变得残忍冷酷。但那不是我。我在学院看到的也不是那种人。我近一半的同学是西班牙裔。他们中有些人就在边境长大。”
I speak both languages. I know both cultures. I've lived in Mexico and traveled all across it. I'll help people. I explained to my mother that good people would always be crossing the border and whether I was in the Border Patrol or not, agents would still be out there arresting them. At least if I'm the one apprehending them, I can offer them some small comfort by speaking with them in their own language, by talking to them with knowledge of their home.
“我两种语言都会说。我了解两种文化。我住在墨西哥，去过那里各地。我会帮助人们。”我向母亲解释，好人总是会越过边境，无论我是否在边境巡逻队，探员们仍然会在外面逮捕他们。如果抓捕他们的人是我，至少我可以和他们用母语交谈，以对他们家乡的了解与他们交谈，从而给他们带来一些小小的安慰。
Fine, my mother said. Fine. But you must understand, you are stepping into a system with little regard for people. For several moments, silence hung between us. I said, I'm not going to become someone else.
“好吧，”我母亲说，“好吧。但你必须明白，你正在踏入一个几乎不顾及人的体系。”沉默在我和她之间持续了片刻。我说：“我不会变成另一个人。”
After graduating from the Academy, we were deployed to our respective field stations. We caught our first dope load only two days after arriving on duty. They must have seen us coming across the desert, said Cole, our supervisor. We fanned out to comb the hillsides, and after 10 minutes, we had recovered two backpacks filled with food and clothes, and four additional bundles wrapped in sugar sacks spray painted black.
从学院毕业后，我们被部署到各自的现场站点。我们上任才两天就查获了第一批毒品。“他们一定看到了我们穿过沙漠，”我们的主管科尔说。我们散开搜查山坡，10分钟后，我们找回了两个装满食物和衣服的背包，以及另外四个用黑色喷漆喷过的糖袋包裹。
Those ought to be about 50 pounds each, Cole said. He kicked one of the bundles with his foot. 250 pounds of dope. Not bad for your second day in the field. I asked Cole if we should follow their trail up into the pass, if we should try to track down the backpackers.
“那些应该各重约50磅，”科尔说。他用脚踢了踢其中一个包裹。“250磅毒品。对你们第二天上班来说不错。”我问科尔我们是否应该追踪它们的痕迹进入隘口，是否应该尝试追踪那些背包客。
Hell, no, he said. You don't want to bring in any bodies with your dope, if you can help it. Suspects mean you have a smuggling case on your hands and that's a hell of a lot of paperwork. We'd have to stay and work a double shift just to write it up.
“去死吧，”他说。“如果可以的话，你不希望在搞毒品案时带上尸体。嫌疑人意味着你手头要处理走私案件，那是该死的一大堆文书工作。我们得留下来加班加点才能把它写完。”
He smiled. Abandoned loads are easy, though. You'll see.
他笑了。“不过，丢弃的货物很容易处理。你会看到的。”
Cole had us dump the backpacks and I watched as several of my classmates ripped and tore the clothing, scattering it among the tangled branches of mesquite and palo verde. In one of the backpacks, I found a laminated prayer card depicting Saint Jude, a tongue of flames hovering above his head. Morales found a pack of cigarettes and sat smoking on a rock as others laughed loudly, stepping on a heap of food. Nearby, Hart giggled and shouted to us as he pissed on a pile of ransacked belongings. As we hiked with the bundles back to the vehicles, the February sun grew low in the sky, casting a warm light across the desert.
科尔让我们扔掉背包，我看着我的几个同学撕碎了衣服，散落在牧豆树和帕洛佛得树纠缠的枝条间。在一个背包里，我发现了一张圣裘德的层压祈祷卡，他头顶上方悬浮着一道火焰。莫拉莱斯发现了一包香烟，坐在石头上吸着，其他人大声笑着，踩在一堆食物上。附近，哈特咯咯笑着，在我们向他尿在一堆被洗劫的财物上时对我们大喊大叫。当我们带着包裹走回车上时，二月的太阳在天空中沉了下去，给沙漠投下了一道温暖的光芒。
After sundown, Cole sent Morales up a hill near the highway with a thermal reconnaissance camera. Let me borrow your beanie, vato, he said to me. It's cold out. I handed it to him and stayed inside the vehicle with the others.
日落后，科尔派莫拉莱斯带着热成像侦察摄像机上了高速公路附近的一座山。“把你的无檐帽借我戴戴，哥们儿，”他对我说，“外面很冷。”我把它递给他，和其他人留在车里。
An hour later, Morales spotted a group of 10 just east of mile marker five. We rushed out of the car and set out on foot as he guided us in on the radio. But by the time we got there, the group had already scattered. We found them one by one, huddled in the brush and curled up around the trunks of mesquite trees and cholla cactus. Not one of them ran.
一小时后，莫拉莱斯在五号里程碑以东发现了一群10人组。我们冲出车外徒步出发，他通过无线电引导我们。但当我们到达时，人群已经散开了。我们一个接一个地发现他们蜷缩在灌木丛中，盘踞在牧豆树和仙人掌树干周围。没有一个人逃跑。
We made them take off their shoelaces so they couldn't run from us and we sorted through their backpacks, checking for weapons and throwing out their food. We walked all 10 of them single file back to the road. For a while, I walked next to an older man who told me they were all from Michoacan. It's beautiful there, I said. Yes, he replied, but there is no work.
我们让他们脱掉鞋带以免逃跑，我们翻查他们的背包，检查武器并扔掉他们的食物。我们排成一列把他们10个人带回路上。有一段时间，我走在一个老人旁边，他告诉我他们都来自米却肯州。“那里很美，”我说。“是的，”他回答，“但那里没有工作。”
You've been to Michoacan? He asked. I told him I had. Then you must have seen what it is to live in Mexico, he said. And now you see what it's like for us at the border.
“你去过米却肯？”他问。我告诉他我去过。“那你一定见过墨西哥的生活是什么样的，”他说。“现在你看到了我们在边境的生活是什么样的。”
We walked silently next to each other and then, after several minutes, he sighed deeply. Hay mucha desesperación, he told me, almost whispering. I tried to look at his face, but it was too dark.
我们默默地走在一起，几分钟后，他深深地叹了口气。“非常绝望，”他几乎耳语般告诉我。我想看看他的脸，但太黑了。
At the station, I processed the man for deportation. After I'd taken his fingerprints, he asked me if there was any work for him. You don't understand, I said.
在车站，我处理了这个人的驱逐手续。在我采集了他的指纹后，他问我是否有工作给他。“你不明白，”我说。
You've just got to wait here until the bus comes. They'll take you to the headquarters and then onto the border. You'll be back in Mexico very soon.
“你只需要在这里等公共汽车来。他们会把你带到总部，然后带到边境。你很快就会回到墨西哥。”
I understand, he assured me. I just want to know if there's something I can do while I wait, something to help. I can take out the trash or clean out the cells.
“我明白，”他向我保证，“我只是想知道在我等车的时候我能不能做点什么，帮点忙。我可以倒垃圾或清理牢房。”
I want to show you that I'm here to work, that I'm not a bad person. I'm not here to bring in drugs. I'm not here to do anything illegal. I want to work.
“我想向你展示我来这里是为了工作，我不是个坏人。我来这里不是为了贩毒。我来这里不是为了做任何非法的事情。我想工作。”
There are days when I feel I'm becoming good at what I do. And then I wonder, what does it mean to be good at this? I wonder sometimes how I might explain certain things, the sense in what we do when they run from us, scattering into the brush, leaving behind their water jugs and their backpacks full of food and clothes. How to explain what we do when we discover their lay up spots, stocked with water and stashed rations.
有些日子我感觉自己变得很擅长这份工作了。然后我开始怀疑，擅长这份工作意味着什么？我有时怀疑我该如何解释某些事情，当我们做这些事情时有什么意义：他们从我们身边逃跑，散入灌木丛，丢下水壶和装满食物和衣服的背包。当我们发现他们储备了水和口粮的营地时，该如何解释我们的所作所为。
Of course, what you do depends on who you're with. It depends on what kind of agent you are, what kind of agent you want to become. But it's true that we slash their bottles and drain their water into the dry earth. That we dump their backpacks and pile their food and clothes to be crushed and pissed on and stepped over, strewn across the desert floor and set ablaze.
当然，你做什么取决于你和谁在一起。这取决于你是哪种探员，你想成为哪种探员。但事实是，我们划破他们的瓶子，把水排干在干枯的土地上。我们丢弃他们的背包，把食物和衣服堆在一起压碎、尿尿、踩踏，扔得满地都是，然后付之一炬。
Look, it sounds terrible, and maybe it is. But the idea is that when that come out from their hiding places, when they regroup and return to find their stockpiles ransacked and stripped, they'll realize their situation, that they're [BLEEP]. That it's hopeless to continue.
看，这听起来很糟糕，也许确实如此。但想法是，当他们从藏身处出来，重组并返回发现储藏物被洗劫和剥削时，他们会意识到自己的处境，即他们被[哔——]了。继续前进是毫无希望的。
And they'll quit right then and there. They'll save themselves and struggle towards the nearest highway or dirt road to flag down some passing agent. Or they'll head for the nearest parched village to knock on someone's door. Someone who will give them food and water and call us to take them in.
他们会当即放弃。他们会自救并挣扎着走向最近的高速公路或土路，拦下过往的探员。或者他们会前往最近的贫瘠村庄去敲某人的门。那个会给他们食物和水并叫我们来收容他们的人。
That's the idea, the sense in it all. But still, I have nightmares, visions of them staggering through the desert, men from Michoacan, from places I've known. Men lost and wandering without food or water, dying slowly as they look for some road, some village, some way out. In my dreams, I seek them out, searching in vain until finally, I discover their bodies lying face down on the ground before me, dead and stinking on the desert floor. Human waypoints in a vast and smoldering expanse.
这就是想法，这一切的逻辑。但即便如此，我还是会做噩梦，梦见他们在沙漠中蹒跚前行，来自米却肯的男人，来自我认识的地方的人。迷路了，在徘徊，没有食物和水，在寻找某条路、某个村庄、某种出路时慢慢死去。在梦中，我寻找他们，徒劳地搜索，直到最后，我发现他们的尸体脸朝下躺在地面上，死在了沙漠中，散发着恶臭。在这广阔且闷热的荒原上，他们是人类的航点。
After three months, we were finally released from the training unit and dispersed into rotating shifts to work under journeyman agents. I was partnered with Mortenson, a four-year veteran of the patrol. Early one morning, before dawn, Mortenson brought me to the port of entry and we arrested a woman who'd cut a hole in the pedestrian fence.
三个月后，我们终于从训练部门释放，被分散到轮班制下在老探员手下工作。我与莫滕森搭档，他是巡逻队四年的老兵。一天清晨，黎明前，莫滕森带我去了入境口岸，我们逮捕了一名在行人围栏上切开一个洞的女子。
As Mortenson inspected the breach, the girl wept beside me, telling me it was her birthday, that she had just turned 23, pleading for me to let her go and swearing she would never cross again. Mortenson took a long look at the woman and laughed. I booked her last week, he said. The woman spoke hurriedly as we walked back to the parking lot.
当莫滕森检查裂口时，那个女孩在我身边哭泣，告诉我今天是她的生日，她刚满23岁，恳求我放她走，并誓言她再也不会越境。莫滕森看了一眼那个女人，笑了。“我上周刚登记过她，”他说。当我们走回停车场时，那个女人匆忙地说着。
While Mortenson went inside the port of entry, she told me she was from Guadalajara, that she had some problems there. That she had already tried four times to cross. She swore to me that she would stay in Mexico for good this time, that she would finally go back and finish music school. Te lo juro, she said. I promise.
当莫滕森进入入境口岸时，她告诉我她来自瓜达拉哈拉，她在那里遇到了一些问题。她已经尝试过四次越境了。她向我发誓，这次她会永远留在墨西哥，她最终会回去完成音乐学校的学业。“我发誓，”她说。我保证。
She looked at me and smiled. Someday, I'm going to be a singer, you know. I believe it, I said, smiling back.
她看着我笑了。 “总有一天，我会成为一名歌手，你知道吗。” “我相信，”我微笑着回应。
She told me that she thought I was nice and before Mortensen returned, she snuck her counterfeit green card into my hand. I don't want to get in trouble at the processing center like last time, she said. I slipped the card into my pocket. When Mortenson came back, we helped her into the patrol vehicle and drove north towards the station, laughing and applauding as she sang "Bidi Bidi Bom Bom" to us from the back seat.
她告诉我她觉得我很友好，在莫滕森回来之前，她偷偷把她的假绿卡塞进我手里。“我不想像上次那样在处理中心惹麻烦，”她说。我把卡滑进我的口袋。当莫滕森回来后，我们帮她上了巡逻车，向北驶向车站，笑声和掌声中，她在后座为我们唱着《Bidi Bidi Bom Bom》。
She's going to be a singer, I told Mortenson. The woman beamed. Well, [BLEEP], he said, she already is.
“她要成为歌手，”我告诉莫滕森。那个女人容光焕发。“好吧，[哔——]，”他说，“她已经是了。”
Morales was the first to hear him screaming in the distance from one of the spider roads. He hiked for a mile or two and found the kid lying on the ground hysterical. The coyote who left him there told him he was holding back the group and handed him half a liter of water, pointing to some hills in the distance, telling him to walk at them until he found a road. When I arrived with the water, the kid was on the ground next to Morales, lurching in the shade and crying like a child.
莫拉莱斯是第一个在远处听到他在蜘蛛路之一上尖叫的人。他徒步走了一两英里，发现那孩子躺在地上歇斯底里。那个留下他的“郊狼”告诉他，他拖累了小组，并递给他半升水，指向远处的一些山丘，让他朝那里走直到发现路。当我带着水到达时，那孩子在莫拉莱斯旁边，在阴凉处蹒跚且像孩子一样哭泣。
The kid was fat. His pants sagged from his ass and his fly was half open, his zipper broken. His shirt hung loosely from his shoulders, inside out and torn and soaked in sweat.
那孩子很胖。他的裤子从屁股上滑下来，拉链开了一半，坏了。他的衬衫松松垮垮地挂在肩膀上，反着穿，撕裂了，被汗水浸透。
Morales looked at me and smiled, and then turned to the kid. Your water is here, gordo. I kneeled next to him and handed him the gallon jug. He took a sip and began to pant and groan.
莫拉莱斯看着我笑了，然后转向那孩子。“水来了，胖子。”我在他身边跪下，把加仑水壶递给他。他喝了一口，开始喘气和呻吟。
Drink more, I said, but drink slowly. I can't, he moaned. I'm going to die. No, you're not, I told him. You're still sweating.
“多喝点，”我说，“但慢慢喝。” “我不能，”他呻吟道。“我要死了。” “不，你不会，”我告诉他。“你还在流汗。”
After the kid drank some water, we helped him up and tried walking him through the thicket toward the road. He lagged and staggered, crying out behind us. Ay oficial, he would moan. No puedo, I can't.
在孩子喝了一些水后，我们扶他起来，试着带他穿过灌木丛走向路边。他在我们后面蹒跚滞后，叫喊着。“啊，长官，”他会呻吟，“我不行，我做不到。”
As we crouched and barged through tangled branches, I slowly became overwhelmed by his panic, until finally we broke out of the thicket and spotted the dirt road. You see the trucks, gordo? Can you make it that far? Maybe we should just leave you here. No puedes, verdad?
当我们蹲着穿过纠结的树枝时，我慢慢被他的恐慌淹没，直到最后我们冲出灌木丛，看到了那条土路。“你看到卡车了吗，胖子？你能走到那么远吗？也许我们应该把你留在这里。你做不到，对吧？”
On the ride back to the station, the kid regained some composure. He told me that he was 18, that he planned to go to Oregon to sell heroin. I hear you can make a lot of money that way, he said.
在回车站的路上，那孩子恢复了一些镇定。他告诉我他18岁了，计划去俄勒冈州卖海洛因。“我听说那样能赚很多钱，”他说。
Agents found a man named Martin Ubalda de la Vega and his three companions on the bombing range 10 miles west of the highway. The four men had been in the desert for six days and had wandered in the July heat for more than 48 hours without food or water. By the time of rescue, one of the men had already met his death. One was quickly treated and discharged from the hospital. Another remained in intensive care, recently awoken from a coma, unable to remember his own name.
探员在距离高速公路10英里的轰炸区发现了一个名叫马丁·乌巴尔达·德拉维加的人和他的三个同伴。这四个人在沙漠里待了六天，在七月的酷暑中徘徊了超过48小时，没有食物或水。等到救援时，其中一人已经死亡。一人在医院接受了快速治疗并出院。另一人仍住在重症监护室，刚从昏迷中醒来，记不起自己的名字。
When I arrived at the hospital asking for the third survivor, nurses explained that he was recovering from kidney failure and guided me to his room. I had been charged with watching over de la Vega until his condition was stable, at which point I would transport him to the station to be processed for deportation.
当我到达医院询问第三位幸存者时，护士解释说他正在从肾衰竭中恢复，并带我去了他的房间。我被指派看守德拉维加，直到他的情况稳定，届时我会把他运到车站进行驱逐处理。
I settled in a chair next to him and after several moments of silence, I asked him to tell me about himself. He answered timidly, as if unsure of how to speak. He apologized for his Spanish, explaining that he only knew what they had taught him in school. He came from the jungles of Guerrero, he told me, and in his village, they spoke Mixtec and farmed the green earth.
我在他旁边的一张椅子上安顿下来，沉默了片刻后，我请他告诉我关于他自己的事情。他胆怯地回答，好像不确定如何说话。他为自己的西班牙语道歉，解释说他只懂学校教他的那些。他来自格雷罗州的丛林，他告诉我，在他的村庄里，他们说米斯特克语，耕种着绿色的土地。
He was the father of seven children, he said. Five girls and two boys. His eldest daughter lived in California and he had crossed the border with plans to go live with her and find work. We spent the following hours watching telenovelas and occasionally, he would turn to ask me about the women in America, wondering if they were like the ones on TV.
他说，他是七个孩子的父亲。五个女孩，两个男孩。他的大女儿住在加利福尼亚，他越过边境计划去和她住在一起并找工作。随后的几个小时，我们看着肥皂剧，偶尔他会转过身来问我关于美国的女人，想知道她们是否像电视上的那些一样。
He began to tell me about his youngest daughter, still in Mexico. She just turned 18, he said. You could marry her.
他开始告诉我他最小的女儿，还在墨西哥。 “她刚满18岁，”他说。“你可以娶她。”
Later that afternoon, de la Vega was cleared for release. The nurse brought in his belongings, a pair of blue jeans and sneakers with holes going through the soles. I asked what had happened to his shirt. I don't know, he told me. I looked at the nurse and she shrugged, telling me he had come that way.
那天下午晚些时候，德拉维加被批准释放。护士带进他的财物，一条蓝色牛仔裤和鞋底有洞的运动鞋。我问他的衬衫怎么了。 “我不知道，”他告诉我。我看了一眼护士，她耸了耸肩，告诉我他来的时候就是这样。
We've got no clothes here, she added. As we exited through the hospital lobby, I watched the way people looked at his shirtless body and imagined him alone and half naked in the days to come as he was booked and transferred and finally bussed to the border.
“我们这里没有衣服，”她补充说。当我们穿过医院大厅离开时，我看着人们注视他赤裸上身的样子，想象着他在未来几天里独自一人半裸着身子，被登记、转移，最终被公共汽车送往边境。
When we got to the parking lot, I placed him in the passenger seat of my patrol vehicle and popped the trunk. I walked to the back of the cruiser, unbuttoned my uniform shirt, and removed my white v-neck to give to him. Before leaving town, I asked him if he was hungry. You should eat something now, I told him. At the station, there's only juice and crackers.
当我们到达停车场时，我把他放在巡逻车的乘客座位上，弹开了后备箱。我走到巡逻车后面，解开我的制服衬衫，脱掉我的白色V领内衣递给他。在离开小镇之前，我问他饿不饿。“你现在应该吃点东西，”我告诉他。“在车站，只有果汁和饼干。”
I asked him what he was hungry for. What do Americans eat, he asked. I laughed. Here, we eat mostly Mexican food. He looked at me unbelievingly. But we also eat hamburgers, I said. We pulled into a McDonald's.
我问他想吃什么。“美国人吃什么，”他问。我笑了。 “在这里，我们主要吃墨西哥食物。” 他难以置信地看着我。 “但我们也吃汉堡，”我说。我们开进了麦当劳。
As we drove south along the open highway, I tuned into a Mexican radio station and we listened to the sounds of norteño as he finished his meal. After he finished eating, he sat silently next to me, watching the passing desert.
当我们沿着开阔的高速公路向南行驶时，我调到了一个墨西哥广播电台，我们一边听着墨西哥北部的音乐，一边看着他吃完饭。吃完饭后，他默默地坐在我旁边，看着经过的沙漠。
Then, quietly, as if whispering to me or to someone else, he began to speak of the rains in Guerrero, of the wet and green jungle, and I wondered if he could have ever been made to imagine a place like this. A place where one of his companions would meet his death and another would be made to forget his own name. A landscape where the earth still seethed with volcanic heat.
然后，他安静地，仿佛在对我或其他人低语，开始讲述格雷罗州的雨，潮湿而绿色的丛林，我怀疑他是否曾经想象过这样的地方。一个他的同伴会遇到死亡，另一个会被迫忘记自己名字的地方。一个大地仍然沸腾着火山热浪的景观。
A woman on the south side of the pedestrian fence flagged me down as I passed her on the border road. I stopped my vehicle and went over to her. With panic in her voice, she asked me if I knew about her son. He had crossed days ago, she said. Maybe it was a week ago, she wasn't sure.
当我在边境公路上经过她身边时，行人围栏南侧的一名女子拦住了我。我停下车，走到她身边。她声音里带着恐慌，问我是否知道她儿子的消息。她说，他几天前越境了。也许是一周前，她不确定。
She hadn't heard anything from him-- no one had, and she didn't know if he had been caught or if he was lost somewhere in the desert, or if he was even still alive. Estamos desesperados, she told me, her voice quivering, one hand clawing at her chest and the other trembling against the fence.
她没有收到他的任何消息——没人收到，她不知道他是被抓了，还是迷失在沙漠里的某个地方，或者他是否还活着。“我们很绝望，”她告诉我，声音颤抖，一只手抓着她的胸口，另一只手在围栏上发抖。
I don't remember what I told her, if I took down the man's name or if I gave her a phone number to some faraway office or hotline. But I remember thinking later about de la Vega, about his dead and delirious companions, about all the questions I should have asked the woman.
我不记得我告诉了她什么，我是否记下了那男人的名字，或者我是否给了她某个遥远办公室或热线的电话号码。但我记得后来想到了德拉维加，想到了他死去和神志不清的同伴们，想到了所有我应该问那个女人的问题。
I arrived home that evening and threw my gun belt and uniform across the couch, standing alone in my living room. I called my mother. I'm safe, I told her. I'm home.
那天晚上我回到家，把枪带和制服扔在沙发上，独自站在客厅里。我打电话给母亲。“我很安全，”我告诉她。“我到家了。”
When the call came out on the radio, I braced myself for the smell. That's the worst part, the senior agents would always say. The smell. My first week at the station, one of them suggested I carry a small tin of Vicks VapoRub with me wherever I went. If you come up on a dead body, he would say, rub that [BLEEP] under your nose or else the smell will stay with you for days.
当无线电里传来呼叫时，我做好了忍受气味的心理准备。那是最糟糕的部分，资深探员总是这么说。气味。我刚到车站的第一周，其中一个建议我随身携带一小盒维克斯薄荷膏。他说，如果你遇到尸体，就把它[哔——]涂在鼻子下，否则气味会跟着你好几天。
When I arrived, it was evening and Hart had already been on the scene for half an hour. The body is fresh, he told me, maybe two hours old. Doesn't smell yet.
我到达时已经是傍晚了，哈特已经在现场半小时了。“尸体很新鲜，”他告诉我，“大约两小时前死亡。还没有气味。”
Hart had been flagged down by two boys as he was driving across the reservation. They put rocks in the road, he said, gesturing awkwardly at the boys. He stood for a moment with his hands in his pocket and then asked me, quietly, if I would talk to them. They keep asking me questions, he said. I can't understand them.
哈特在穿过保留地时被两个男孩拦住了。他说，他们把石头放在路上，尴尬地指了指那两个男孩。他把手插在兜里站了一会儿，然后安静地问我是否愿意和他们谈谈。他说：“他们一直问我问题。我听不懂他们。”
One of the boys sat quietly on a rock, looking disoriented. I went over to him and asked him how he knew the dead man. Es mi tio, he told me. He's my uncle. He stared at his hands as he spoke. How old are you? I asked. Dieciseis, 16. I looked at his friend. And you? He looked up from the ground. Diecinueve, he said. 19. The dead man and the two boys all hailed from the same village in Veracruz and had set out together on the journey north. The 19-year-old did most of the talking, telling me that a few hours before the man died, he'd taken two caffeine uppers that border crossers often take for energy, and then washed them down with homemade sugar cane liquor they brought from Veracruz.
其中一个男孩安静地坐在一块石头上，看起来很迷茫。我走过去问他怎么认识那个死者。“是我叔叔，”他告诉我。他是我的叔叔。他说话时盯着自己的手。 “你多大了？”我问。 “十六。” 我看着他的朋友。 “你呢？”他从地上抬头看了看。“十九，”他说。死者和这两个男孩都来自维拉克鲁斯州的同一个村庄，一起踏上了北上的旅程。那个19岁的年轻人说了大部分的话，告诉我那个男人死前几小时，他服用了两片咖啡因兴奋剂——边境越境者经常为了精力服用这种药物——然后用他们从维拉克鲁斯带来的自制甘蔗酒冲服。
A few hours later, he said, the man was staggering around like a drunk, and then he collapsed. I walked over to the body. Hart had placed a shirt over the dead man's face. I lifted it and looked at him. His eyes were closed, white foam had bubbled up and collected between his parted lips, and his face was covered with small red ants, traveling in neat lines towards the moisture.
几小时后，他说，那人像醉鬼一样蹒跚，然后倒下了。我走过去查看尸体。哈特在死者脸上盖了一件衬衫。我掀开它看着他。他的眼睛闭着，白色的泡沫从他分开的嘴唇间冒出来并聚集在一起，他的脸上爬满了红色的小蚂蚁，沿着整齐的线条走向水分。
The 19-year-old told me that the three of them had become separated from the group. Their guide had told them to spread out, to hide in the bushes by the road to wait for the load vehicle. They must have gone too far, he said, because sometime later, they heard a car stop and then drive off and after that, they couldn't find anyone.
那个19岁的年轻人告诉我，他们三个人和队伍走散了。他们的向导告诉他们散开，躲在路边的灌木丛里等待货车。他说，他们一定走得太远了，因为后来他们听到一辆车停下又开走了，在那之后，他们找不到任何人了。
Alone at the edge of the road, they walked for several miles in the August heat until the dead man finally lay down to die. The boys waited beside the road to flag down one of the infrequently passing cars, but no one stopped for them. That's when they put the rocks out, they said, to make the cars stop.
孤独地在路边，他们在八月的酷暑中走了几英里，直到那男人终于躺下死去。男孩们在路边等待，试图拦下一辆不常经过的车，但没有人为他们停下。他们说，就在那时他们放了石头，为了让车停下。
The boys asked me what would happen to the dead man, if they could come with the body to the hospital. I told them that they could not, that they had to stay with us, that they would be processed for deportation and the body would be turned over to the tribal police.
男孩们问我死者会发生什么，他们能不能带着尸体去医院。我告诉他们不能，他们必须留在这里，他们将被驱逐处理，尸体将交给部落警察。
They asked if the body would come back to Mexico with them, if they could bring it back to their village. I told them that they could not, that the body would be taken to the county medical examiner, who would try to determine the cause of death.
他们问尸体是否会和他们一起回墨西哥，他们是否能把它带回村庄。我告诉他们不能，尸体将被带到县法医那里，他们会试图确定死因。
I told the boys that they would be taken to the sector headquarters, where they would meet with the Mexican consul. That it was they who would make arrangements for the repatriation of the body to Mexico.
我告诉男孩们他们将被带到部门总部，在那里他们会见到墨西哥领事。是他们会做出尸体遣返回墨西哥的安排。
As I spoke, the man's nephew stared at the ground. The boys didn't want to leave the body. And even as I explained the procedures to them, I began quietly doubting, given what I knew from my short time on the border, whether they would actually see the console, whether the consulate would actually arrange for the body to go back to Mexico. Whether the boys would even receive a piece of paper to help explain to the dead man's family what had befallen him on the journey north.
我说话时，那男人的侄子盯着地面。男孩们不想离开尸体。甚至当我向他们解释流程时，鉴于我在边境短暂时间所了解的情况，我开始悄悄怀疑，他们是否真的会见到领事，领事馆是否真的会安排尸体回到墨西哥。男孩们甚至是否会收到一张纸来帮助向死者的家人解释他在北上旅途中遭遇了什么。
Before the boys were loaded into the transport unit, I went to them and told them I was sorry for their loss. It's a hard thing, I said. I told them that if they ever decided to cross again, they must not cross in the summer. It's too hot, I said. To cross in the heat is to risk one's life. They nodded.
在男孩们被装上运送车之前，我走到他们身边，告诉他们我为他们的损失感到抱歉。“这是一件很难过的事情，”我说。我告诉他们，如果他们决定再次越境，绝对不要在夏天越境。“太热了，”我说。“在酷暑中越境是冒着生命危险。”他们点了点头。
I told them that many people died here. That in the summer, people died every day, year after year, and many more were found hovering at the edge of death. The boys thanked me, I think, and were placed into the transport unit and driven away.
我告诉他们许多人死在这里。在夏天，人们每天都在死，年复一年，还有更多人被发现徘徊在死亡边缘。男孩们感谢了我，我想，然后他们被放进运送车带走了。
The sun had already began to set, as I left the body in a cast of warm light on the storm clouds gathering in the south. I drove toward the storm. When the first rain drops began to hit my windshield, I could hear the dispatch operator radio to Hart, who had stayed behind with the body, that the tribal police didn't have any officers available and he'd have to wait with the dead man a while longer.
夕阳已经开始落下，我把尸体留在了风暴云在南方聚集的温暖光影中。我向着风暴开车。当第一滴雨点开始打在挡风玻璃上时，我听到调度员通过无线电告诉哈特，他留下来陪着尸体，说部落警察没有可用的人员，他还得再和死者待一会儿。
Later that night, at the end of our shift, I saw Hart back at the station and asked what had happened with the body. He told me the storm had finally come and dispatch had told him to just leave the body there. The tribal police wouldn't have an officer to take charge of it until the next day.
那天晚上晚些时候，在我们轮班结束时，我在车站看到了哈特，问尸体怎么处理了。他告诉我风暴终于来了，调度员告诉他把尸体留在那里就行。部落警察要到第二天才有警官去接手。
It's all right, he said. They've got the coordinates. I asked him if it had been strange waiting there in the dark watching over the body of a dead man. Not really, he said. At least he didn't smell yet.
“没关系，”他说。“他们有坐标。” 我问他待在那里在黑暗中守着一具死尸是否很奇怪。 “不怎么奇怪，”他说。“至少他还不需要处理气味。”
We stood for a few more minutes, talking about the storm and about the human body that lay there in the desert in the dark and in the rain. And we talked of the animals that might come in the night and of the humidity and the deadly heat that would come with the morning. We talked and then we went home.
我们站了几分钟，谈论着暴风雨，谈论着那具躺在沙漠中黑暗和雨水里的尸体。我们谈论了可能在夜里出没的动物，谈论了湿度，谈论了早晨随之而来的致命高温。我们谈完后就回家了。
At the end of my shift on Christmas Eve, I returned home well after midnight and woke my mother, who had come to stay with me for the holiday. We sat together in my living room, talking through the early hours of the morning, drinking eggnog and stringing popcorn around an artificial tree.
平安夜轮班结束时，我过了午夜回到家，叫醒了来陪我过节的母亲。我们坐在客厅里，聊到清晨，喝着蛋酒，在人造树上挂着爆米花串。
My mother asked me about my shift. It was fine, I said. She asked if I was liking the work, if I was learning what I wanted. I knew what she was asking but I didn't have the energy to think of it, to weigh where I was against what had brought me there.
母亲问起我的轮班情况。 “还好，”我说。她问我是不是喜欢这份工作，是否学到了我想学的。我知道她在问什么，但我没有精力去思考，去衡量我所处的位置和带我来这里的初衷。
The work isn't really something to like, I told her curtly. There's not a lot of time to sit around and reflect on things. It's my job, I told her, and I'm trying to get used to it. I'm trying to get good at it. I can figure out what that means later.
“这份工作真的没什么可喜欢的，”我冷淡地告诉她。“没有多少时间坐下来反思事情。这是我的工作，”我告诉她，“我正在努力习惯它。我正在努力做好它。至于那意味着什么，我以后再弄明白。”
You know, my mother said, it's not just your safety I worry about. I know how a person can become lost in their job. You asked me once how it felt looking back on my career.
“你知道，”母亲说，“我担心的不仅仅是你的安全。我知道一个人是如何在工作中迷失自我的。你曾经问过我，回顾我的职业生涯感觉如何。”
The Park Service is an institution. If I'm honest, I can see now that I spent my career slowly losing a sense of purpose, even though I was close to the outdoors, close to the places I loved. I don't want that for you.
“公园管理局是一个机构。老实说，我现在可以看出，我的职业生涯是在慢慢失去目标感，即使我身处户外，靠近我热爱的地方。我不希望你那样。”
I cut my mother off. I was too exhausted to consider my sense of purpose, too afraid to tell my mother about the dreams of dead bodies, about the hands I had seen shaking at the fence.
我打断了母亲。我太累了，无法思考我的目标感，太害怕告诉母亲关于死尸的梦，关于我在围栏处看到的颤抖的双手。
What I couldn't articulate to her until years later was that, in a way, I hadn't learned anything from my work that I didn't already know. People were risking their lives to cross an unnatural divide, while others were being employed to stop them. And there was, of course, a profound violence in all of this. People were dying with nobody hoping or intending for them to die. But to see it firsthand, day in and day out, it seems somehow more awful than I could have ever imagined.
直到多年后我才对她说明的是，在某种程度上，我并没有从工作中学会任何我不知道的东西。人们冒着生命危险越过一道不自然的鸿沟，而其他人被雇佣来阻止他们。当然，这一切中有着深刻的暴力。人们在死，而没有任何人希望或打算让他们死。但亲眼看到这一切，日复一日，这似乎比我能想象的要糟糕得多。
After dark, the scope truck spotted a group of 20 heading north toward the bombing range. The operator said they were moving slowly, that it looked like there might be women and children in the group. He guided us in and we quickly located their trail and then lost it again across a stretch of hard packed desert pavement.
天黑后，侦察车发现了一群20人正向北前往轰炸区。调度员说他们移动缓慢，看起来队伍里可能有妇女和儿童。他引导我们进入，我们迅速锁定了他们的足迹，然后在一段坚硬的沙漠地面上又丢了。
We split up and combed the hillside, hunting for toe digs and kicked-over rocks. As I looked desperately for a sign of their passage, I thought of the deadly expanses that stretched between here and the nearest highway, the nearest place the group might stop for aid.
我们分头行动，在山坡上搜寻脚印和踢翻的石头。当我绝望地寻找他们经过的迹象时，我想到了在这片荒原与最近的高速公路之间蔓延的致命空间，那是这群人可能获得援助的最近的地方。
On the walk back to our vehicle, I became furious. There were supposed to be 20 of them. They were supposed to be slow. But still, I couldn't catch up. I couldn't stay on their sign. I couldn't even get close enough to hear them in the distance.
走回车上的路上，我愤怒了。本应有20个人。他们本应是缓慢的。但即便如此，我还是追不上。我无法留在他们的痕迹上。我甚至无法靠近到能在远处听到他们的声音。
And so now, they remained out there in the desert, men, women, and children. Entire families invisible and unheard. And I was powerless to help them, powerless to keep them from straying through the night.
所以现在，他们仍然留在沙漠里，男人、女人和孩子。整个家庭隐形且无人知晓。而我无能为力去帮助他们，无能为力去阻止他们徘徊在黑夜中。
Francisco Cantu, reading excerpts of what's going to be a book next year called "The Line Becomes a River." A version of his account originally ran in Ploughshares. Coming up, we turn from a family where the mom does not want her kid at the border to a mom who goes there herself to run guns, illegally, across it. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
弗朗西斯科·坎图，正在朗读明年将出版的名为《河流化为线》的书中的节选。他的叙述版本最初发表在《犁头》杂志上。接下来，我们从一个母亲不想让孩子去边境的家庭，转到一个母亲自己去边境非法走私枪支的家庭。一分钟后，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's show, "OK, I'll Do It," people stepping up to the plate to do dangerous things that most of us do not do. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题。今天节目的主题是“好吧，我来做”，人们挺身而出，去做大多数人不会做的危险事情。我们来到了节目的第二幕。
Act 2, "Da Do Run Guns, Mom, Da Do Run Guns." As we get older, if we're lucky, we get to see our parents in a new light. We get to learn parts about them that we did not really get when we were kids. Reya El-Salahi is a journalist in London. And in her case, what she learned about her mom is that her mom ran missions for a guerrilla movement in Africa.
第二幕，“妈妈走私枪支”。随着年龄的增长，如果我们幸运的话，我们会以新的眼光看待父母。我们能了解到他们小时候我们没能理解的那一部分。雷亚·埃尔-萨拉希是伦敦的一名记者。在她身上，她了解到关于她母亲的事是，她母亲曾为非洲的一个游击队组织执行过任务。
A few years ago, I found out, just months before she met my dad, my mum had been in a fake marriage. She was a university student at the time and her sham husband-to-be was a man called Laurence. They boarded a plane, exchanged rings, and checked into a hotel in Zambia as husband and wife.
几年前，我发现，就在我母亲认识我父亲的前几个月，她曾有过一段假婚姻。当时她是一名大学生，而她未来的虚假丈夫是一个叫劳伦斯的人。他们登上一架飞机，交换戒指，并以夫妻身份入住赞比亚的一家酒店。
For Laurence, it was his first time. First time on the continent.
对劳伦斯来说，这是他第一次。第一次来到这片大陆。
That's my mum. She'd been to Africa before, but Laurence hadn't. Like a lot of newlyweds, they got a car together, a brand new, spacious Land Rover.
那是我的母亲。她以前去过非洲，但劳伦斯没有。像许多新婚夫妇一样，他们一起买了一辆车，一辆全新的、宽敞的路虎。
We bought the Land Rover in Botswana. We drove it up to Zambia and it was then secretly modified to be able to carry guns. So there was a false petrol tank which looked as though we just had an extra petrol tank put in for our trips. And then we had to drive it across, back to Botswana, with guns in it. That was pretty scary.
“我们在博茨瓦纳买了那辆路虎。我们把它开到赞比亚，然后它被秘密改装成能够携带枪支。所以有一个伪装的油箱，看起来就像我们为了旅行多装了一个油箱一样。然后我们必须开车穿过它，带枪回到博茨瓦纳。那非常吓人。”
It was 1971. Posing as white tourists, they'd drive guns and guerrilla fighters as close to the border of South Africa as they could and drop them off over and over again for three months.
那是1971年。伪装成白人游客，他们在三个月内一次又一次地驾驶车辆，尽可能把枪支和游击队员送到南非边境附近，然后把他们放下。
We were undercover agents.
“我们是卧底特工。”
Undercover agents for the African National Congress, the party Nelson Mandela led to end apartheid in South Africa to give non-whites equal rights and the right to vote.
非洲人国民大会的卧底特工，那是纳尔逊·曼德拉领导的终结南非种族隔离，给予非白人平等权利和投票权的政党。
What we were meant to be doing was smuggling men and arms down from Zambia down into a part of Botswana, southern Botswana, where they could get over the border into South Africa.
“我们要做的就是把人和武器从赞比亚走私到博茨瓦纳，博茨瓦纳南部，在那里他们可以越过边境进入南非。”
I learned the details of my mother's secret from a book when I was 25, the same age she was when she went on the mission. It was the first time she'd ever told her story and my mind was completely blown. She was a conventional mum in so many ways. She drove me to school each day and was home cooking dinner every night.
我在25岁时从一本书中得知了母亲秘密的细节，那正是她去执行任务时的年纪。那是她第一次讲述自己的故事，我的大脑完全震撼了。在许多方面，她是一个传统的妈妈。她每天开车送我上学，每天晚上在家做饭。
Growing up, I loved ice skating. My friends' parents would join in, but my mom would always watch from the side, too worried about breaking bones. She was that kind of mum. How was this the same person who, at my age, was smuggling guns for guerrilla fighters? And why would she give that up for the life she had with us?
成长过程中，我喜欢滑冰。朋友们的父母会加入，但妈妈总是从旁边看着，太担心骨折了。她就是那种妈妈。怎么会是同一个人在我这个年纪为游击队员走私枪支？为什么她会为了与我们一起的生活而放弃这一切？
Did you feel any sense of regret? Given that you'd had this hugely exciting, unique experience in your early 20s, to spend the latter part of your 20s and early 30s taking life in a very different direction, was there any sense of regret?
“你有没有后悔过？考虑到你在20出头时有过这种极其令人兴奋、独特的经历，而你在20多岁后期和30多岁初期却朝一个非常不同的方向生活，有没有后悔的感觉？”
Never, never, never. If I think about the one thing that I feel I've done fairly well, it's bringing up you lot. I didn't find it fulfilling enough. I always needed to be doing something that was for me, as well. But I've never regretted that. But also, I felt very good that I stepped up to the challenge.
“绝不，绝不，绝不。如果我认为有一件事我做得还不错，那就是把你们这群孩子抚养大。我没觉得它不够充实。我一直需要做点什么，那也是为了我自己的。但我从不后悔。而且，我觉得我挺身而出迎接挑战，感觉非常好。”
I just can't believe how fundamentally her life changed in such a short space of time. I'm 30 years old. I'm starting to see my female friends make the same choices my mom made, to get married and have children, setting aside their careers and aspirations in ways my male friends never seem to. And to be honest, I can't imagine following the same path. I just don't relate to it at all because she raised me not to relate to it.
我简直不敢相信她的生活在如此短的时间内发生了多么根本性的改变。我30岁了。我开始看到我的女性朋友做着我妈妈做的同样的选择，结婚生子，撇开事业和抱负，这是我的男性朋友似乎从未做过的。老实说，我无法想象走同样的道路。我根本无法联系起来，因为她抚养我长大，让我不要去联系。
So how did this fearless young woman turn into the mother I'd grown up with? To answer that, I took the 90-minute bus ride to my family home in Oxford and sat down for breakfast with my mum in a room filled with her and my dad's old books. And for the first time, she and I talked in depth about what really happened back then.
那么，这个无畏的年轻女性是如何变成我从小长大的妈妈的？为了回答这个问题，我坐了90分钟的公共汽车来到牛津的家里，和妈妈在装满她和我父亲旧书的房间里吃早餐。这是第一次，她和我深入探讨了当时真正发生了什么。
Do you think if you'd asked a good group of your friends what sort of a person you were that time, how would they have described you?
“如果你问一群你的好朋友，他们当时会如何形容你是什么样的人？”
Oh. What a question. I have no idea, all sorts of things. I was a good time girl, I liked partying. I liked-- I had boyfriends. I liked to do all sorts of pleasant things. And I was quite indulged and I came from a family which, at that time, was quite well off. So I had the choice to do all sorts of things that I took for granted.
“哦。什么问题啊。我不知道，各种各样的吧。我是一个追求快乐的女孩，我喜欢聚会。我喜欢——我有男朋友。我喜欢做各种各样的愉快事情。而且我很受宠，我来自一个当时相当富裕的家庭。所以我可以选择做各种我认为理所当然的事情。”
My mom grew up in a Jewish family in Newcastle. It's an industrial city in North England. She lived her life like many students in the late '60s and early '70s, taking part in anti-apartheid demonstrations and marching in protests against the Vietnam War. And when she was approached by a man claiming to be a student, as a cover for recruiting young white Londoners to risk their lives running people and weapons into South Africa, she went for it. My mum doubted she'd be killed if caught, but she did worry they might be imprisoned or deported.
我妈妈在纽卡斯尔的一个犹太家庭长大。那是英格兰北部的一个工业城市。她像60年代末和70年代初的许多学生一样生活，参加反种族隔离示威，在抗议越战的游行中行进。当一个声称是学生的男人接洽她，作为招募年轻白人伦敦人冒险运送人员和武器进入南非的掩护时，她同意了。我妈妈怀疑如果被抓住她会被杀，但她确实担心他们可能会被监禁或驱逐出境。
My mother signed onto the covert operation. She was assigned a partner, her fake husband Laurence, and together, they were given training. How to tell when you're being followed, where to leave secret messages, and why to never write mission details down. She's a sociable person and it was this last point that proved the hardest for my mum. Not being able to talk to anyone, not even her parents, about what she was really doing.
我母亲签署了这项秘密行动。她被指派了一个搭档，她的假丈夫劳伦斯，他们一起接受了训练。如何分辨是否被跟踪，在哪里留下秘密信息，以及为什么永远不要写下任务细节。她是一个善于社交的人，正是最后一点证明对我母亲来说最难。不能和任何人说话，甚至不能和她的父母谈论她真正在做的事情。
Part of me wanted to tell-- to tell my friends, who I knew would be interested and impressed, this is what I'm going to do.
“我的一部分想说——想告诉我的朋友们，我知道他们会感兴趣并留下深刻印象，这就是我要做的事情。”
But you didn't.
“但你没说。”
No, no, no. I didn't. I didn't because we were told we'd put people's lives at risk.
“不，不，不。我没有。我没有，因为我们被告知那会置他人于危险之中。”
The deception fascinated me. I couldn't get my head around it. It seemed beyond her, somehow. She was never a cool mom. To think she could travel with a cover story and a fake marriage, and she kept it up for three months. The mission was dangerous, but they didn't spend all of their time, or even most of it, racing through the African bush with machine guns hidden in the gas tank.
这种欺骗深深吸引了我。我无法理解。这似乎不知何故超出了她的能力。她从来不是一个酷妈妈。想到她可以带着封面故事和虚假婚姻去旅行，并且保持了三个月。任务很危险，但他们并没有花所有的时间，甚至大部分时间，在非洲灌木丛中带着隐藏在油箱里的机枪赛跑。
We spent a lot of time looking at animals, which I had never done before. Because we were near a game reserve and that's one of the things tourists do and honeymoon couples do. So we did all the things we knew we had to do to look plausible.
“我们花了很多时间观察动物，这是我以前从未做过的。因为我们在禁猎区附近，那是游客和蜜月夫妇会做的事情之一。所以我们做了我们知道必须做的一切，看起来很可信。”
Was there no sense-- or was there any sense, I should ask, are people really going to buy this?
“有没有——或者是有没有这种感觉，我应该问，人们真的会相信吗？”
Oh, I had that all the time. I was really anxious that they wouldn't buy it.
“哦，我一直有这种感觉。我非常焦虑他们不会相信。”
Why?
“为什么？”
Because it wasn't true. [LAUGHS] To me, it was blindingly obvious that we weren't a honeymoon couple.
“因为它不是真的。[笑] 对我来说，我们不是蜜月夫妇这件事是显而易见的。”
My mother and Laurence did share a room, but not like that.
我母亲和劳伦斯确实共享一个房间，但不是那种方式。
Did you think there was any chemistry between you?
“你认为你们之间有任何化学反应吗？”
No. No, there wasn't. People don't ask questions. People didn't ask questions. We were a European couple. We were going to safari, if anybody asked us, for two or three months. And that was that.
“没有。没有。没有。人们不问问题。人们不问问题。我们是一对欧洲夫妇。如果有人问我们，我们就去游猎，待两三个月。就是这样。”
What was the dynamic like between you and your fake husband?
“你和你的假丈夫之间的动态是什么样的？”
I don't think we talked like that.
“我不认为我们那样交流。”
Because you didn't know each other.
“因为你们互不认识。”
We didn't know each other and he was very cool. He was very cool. He was very cool and reserved. And I was battling with these anxieties on my own.
“我们互不认识，而且他很酷。他很酷。他很酷且矜持。而我独自一人在与这些焦虑作斗争。”
What did you talk about?
“你们谈论什么？”
We talked about our lives and we probably discussed various things. I don't remember.
“我们谈论我们的生活，我们可能讨论过各种各样的事情。我不记得了。”
You say that as though you weren't actually spending time together when the doors were closed. Did you feel as though, once you were able to drop the act, you were back to being by yourself, even if you were sharing a space?
“你说的好像你们在门关上时并没有真正共处一样。你是否觉得，一旦你可以放下伪装，你就回到了独自一人的状态，即使你们共享一个空间？”
Yes. Yeah, I did. That's right. You've hit the nail on the head.
“是的。是的，确实如此。你一针见血了。”
The downtime was frustrating. There were times that the mission felt poorly planned. Sometimes the men they were meant to help were too drunk to travel. And always, the fear of being found out hung over them. The stickiest it got was one time, they got lost and accidentally crossed over the border into Rhodesia and came face to face with armed guards, who were known to take pot shots at anyone who wasn't meant to be there.
空闲时间令人沮丧。有时任务感觉计划不周。有时他们打算帮助的人喝得太醉无法旅行。而且，被发现的恐惧总是笼罩着他们。最棘手的一次是，他们迷路了，意外越过边境进入罗得西亚，与武装警卫面对面，这些警卫以向任何不该在那里的人开枪射击而闻名。
That was very scary, going into Rhodesia. Coming in in a way that-- from a place they weren't expecting white-- anybody, actually, to come through, but certainly not white tourists. I think we were running out of petrol, too. So at some point, a black South African came and asked us for a lift while we were being processed.
“那非常吓人，进入罗得西亚。以一种他们没预料到会有——从一个他们没预料到白人会穿过的地方进入，其实任何人都不应该，但肯定不是白人游客。我想我们的汽油也快用完了。所以就在我们要被处理时，一个黑人南非人过来让我们搭便车。”
So while you're going through the border gates.
“所以当你穿过边境大门的时候。”
Yes. Would we give him a lift to Chobe, which was the northernmost part of Botswana, just on the border with Zambia. And we had to be very cold and unfriendly and say no. And that felt terrible.
“是的。我们会带他去乔贝吗，那是博茨瓦纳的最北端，就在赞比亚边境。我们不得不表现得非常冷漠和不友好，说不。那感觉糟透了。”
It felt mean and horrible. And afterwards, Laurence said he thought he was planted, that it was a test. But he didn't tell me that till-- that he thought that. I hadn't thought at the time. He thought it much later and it could have been. Who knows?
那感觉很卑鄙且可怕。后来劳伦斯说他认为那是被安插的，那是一个考验。但他直到后来才告诉我——他那么认为。我当时没想过。他很久以后才想到，这可能是真的。谁知道呢？
A test by who?
“什么人的考验？”
Oh, the Rhodesian police. The Rhodesian border police.
“哦，罗得西亚警察。罗得西亚边境警察。”
It was frightening, but my mother and Laurence weren't close, so of course she didn't really talk to him about it.
这很吓人，但我母亲和劳伦斯并不亲近，所以她当然没有真正和他谈过这件事。
And sometimes, that was frustrating. I used to talk to Jimmy in my head.
“有时，这令人沮丧。我过去常在心里和吉米说话。”
That was your real boyfriend?
“那是你真正的男朋友？”
That was my real boyfriend, yes.
“那是我真正的男朋友，是的。”
Before the mission, my mom lived in Tanzania as a research student for two years. During that time, she had a love affair with a black South African man called Jimmy, who was active with the ANC. She has talked about him before, but until now, I didn't know the finer details of their relationship.
在任务之前，我妈妈在坦桑尼亚作为研究学生生活了两年。在此期间，她和一个叫吉米的黑人南非男人有过一段恋情，他活跃在非国大。她以前谈过他，但直到现在，我才知道他们关系的细节。
Why I'm hesitating is because he wasn't my boyfriend. As I say, I knew when I left Tanzania-- it wasn't stated, but we both knew that was likely to be the end of the relationship because he was completely committed to underground work of the ANC.
“我之所以犹豫，是因为他并不是我的男朋友。正如我所说，我知道当我离开坦桑尼亚时——虽然没明说，但我们都知道那很可能是这段关系的终点，因为他完全致力于非国大的地下工作。”
So when you decided to take this mission, you did have a boyfriend?
“所以当你决定执行这个任务时，你确实有一个男朋友？”
Yes.
“是的。”
I didn't know that.
“我不知道。”
Well, but he was in jail-- [LAUGHS] in Tanzania and then sent to the Soviet Union. And I was in England.
“嗯，但他当时在坦桑尼亚坐牢——[笑] 然后被送到了苏联。而我在英国。”
Even though they weren't together at that point, and telling him anything was off limits, my mom joined the ANC partly because of Jimmy.
尽管那时他们没有在一起，而且告诉他任何事情都是禁区，但我母亲加入非国大在某种程度上是因为吉米。
I wanted to do something. I suppose, in some ways, also to impress him and to show that I was serious about things that I said I believed in.
“我想做点什么。我想，在某种程度上，也是为了给他留下深刻印象，并表明我对我说我相信的事情是认真的。”
I'm completely in awe of what she did. But knowing that Jimmy was, in part, why she did it was a bit of a letdown. It made me realize we're very different in how we're motivated. Jimmy found out about my mom's mission and wrote to her. He said how proud he was, but also warned her never to talk about it.
我对她的所作所为完全敬畏。但知道吉米在某种程度上是她这样做的原因有点让人失望。这让我意识到我们在动力方面有很大不同。吉米发现了妈妈的任务并写信给她。他说他有多骄傲，但也警告她永远不要谈论它。
The letters continued for a while longer, but she never saw him again. Years later, when a book about the operation, called The London Recruits, came out, my mother heard through the grapevine that Jimmy had been killed in action. But to this day, his body's never been found.
信件又持续了一段时间，但她再也没见过他。多年后，当一本关于这次行动的书《伦敦新兵》出版时，我妈妈通过小道消息听说吉米在战斗中阵亡了。但直到今天，他的尸体从未被发现。
Do you think, to a certain extent, that I idealize a period of your life that was essentially a three-month period and nothing more? Do you think I romanticize it as more than, perhaps, it was to you?
“你认为，在一定程度上，我是否理想化了你生命中本质上只有三个月、别无其他的一段时期？你认为我把它浪漫化为比它对你而言可能有的更多吗？”
Oh, definitely. Definitely. I think that that's why I was reluctant, in the first place, to talk about The London Recruits. Because I knew an awful lot of people who had done and continued doing a hell of a lot more. And it didn't feel like the pinnacle. If felt like something good to do. I was glad to do it.
“哦，肯定。肯定。我想这就是我起初不愿谈论《伦敦新兵》的原因。因为我知道很多做得更多、继续做得更多的人。它感觉不像是顶峰。它感觉是一件好事。我很高兴能做它。”
A few months after my mother returned home from her mission, she was introduced to the man who'd become her real husband, my dad. They came from completely different worlds. He was Muslim from Sudan and there was a considerable age gap. But for my mum, the relationship just clicked, especially because of what she'd just gone through.
我母亲从任务归来后几个月，她被介绍给了成为她真正丈夫的人，也就是我的父亲。他们来自完全不同的世界。他是来自苏丹的穆斯林，而且年龄有相当大的差距。但对我妈妈来说，这段关系一拍即合，特别是考虑到她刚刚经历的一切。
That mission was part of a huge developmental change for me of what I cared about and believed in, reflected in the kinds of friendships that I had and the kinds of lover I was interested in.
“那个任务是我在我在意和相信的事情上发生巨大发展变化的一部分，反映在我结交的朋友种类和我感兴趣的爱人种类上。”
How much do you think the decision to marry someone, as you say, who was from a very different background from you, was an extension of putting your politics into action?
“你认为决定嫁给一个正如你所说，背景和你截然不同的人，在多大程度上是将你的政治信仰付诸行动的延伸？”
I would hate it to come across as some kind of, right, I have married this person as a political statement. Because I didn't. It was because I loved him. But I think that it was a confirmation of who I'd become.
“如果给人留下一种，我是作为一种政治声明嫁给这个人的印象，我会很讨厌。因为我没有。那是因为我爱他。但我认为这证实了我已经变成了什么样的人。”
So they married. My dad got a job in the Middle East and together, they started a family in Qatar. We grew up between Qatar and London. My mom tried to stay politically active with other forms of work, from journalism to publishing.
所以他们结婚了。我父亲在中东找到了一份工作，他们一起在卡塔尔组建了家庭。我们在卡塔尔和伦敦之间长大。妈妈尝试通过其他形式的工作保持政治活跃，从新闻业到出版业。
But eventually she gave up on all of that. She'd left her independent life behind to follow my father to a place where, she admits, she was cut off from everyone and everything she previously knew and loved, and turned her attention to raising a family. She never did anything like she'd done in southern Africa again and she never talked about it.
但最终她放弃了这一切。她抛下了独立的生活，跟随我父亲去了一个地方，她承认，在那里她与她以前认识和爱过的人和事物隔绝了，并将注意力转向了抚养家庭。她再也没有做过像在非洲南部那样的事情，也从未谈论过它。
It was always so confusing that there she was, this mumsie mum, a woman dedicated to supporting a man-- my dad-- but constantly telling my sister and I not to be, making us focus on putting ourselves first. Age 12 or 13, she encouraged me to get my first job, helping out at a bed and breakfast in my neighborhood, cleaning rooms and doing laundry after school. My mom said it was important I knew the value of hard work and could appreciate the independence of making my own money. It was years before my elder brothers were taught the same lesson.
这一切总是如此令人困惑，她曾是那样一个妈妈味的妈妈，一个致力于支持一个男人——我的父亲——但不断地告诉我和姐姐不要这样，让我们专注于把自己放在第一位。12或13岁时，她鼓励我得到了第一份工作，在附近的一家民宿帮忙，放学后打扫房间和洗衣服。妈妈说这很重要，让我知道努力工作的价值，并能欣赏自己赚钱的独立性。我哥哥们被教导同样的教训是在多年后。
Later on, when I was building my career and living miles away from friends and family, I'd call my mom moaning about being so far away and the impact it was having on my love life. She'd always told me the same thing.
后来，当我建立自己的事业并远离朋友和家人居住时，我会打电话给妈妈，抱怨离得太远以及它对我的爱情生活产生的影响。她总是告诉我同样的事情。
Focus on the future. Independence and work come before love. Knowing how committed she'd been to her mission might have helped me better understand where she was coming from. She hadn't always been a mum.
“专注于未来。独立和工作先于爱情。”知道她对自己的任务有多么投入，可能有助于我更好地理解她的初衷。她并不总是那样一个妈妈。
I didn't know the full extent of what happened until I was well in my 20s, in terms of your experience of this mission. Why didn't you tell me, tell your children, what you did? Did you think we'd judge you?
“直到我20多岁，就你在这个任务中的经历而言，我才知道事情的全貌。为什么你不告诉我，告诉你孩子们，你做了什么？你认为我们会评判你吗？”
Well, you judge me all the time.
“嗯，你一直在评判我。”
That's because I love you. But I think--
“那是因为我爱你。但我认为——”
You judge me whatever I do.
“不管我做什么，你都在评判我。”
I think I judge you because I look at a lot of the decisions that you made when you were around the same age as me and I find it incredible that you made those decisions and then went on to live a life that I can't quite imagine myself living, in terms of putting relationships with men at the forefront of the decisions that I make. You always brought me up very focused on career, on education, not on relationships. But that's completely at odds with the decision that you made when you were the age that I am now. You, to a certain extent, dropped everything you had previously been for a relationship.
“我想我评判你是通过看你在和我差不多大时所做的一系列决定，我发现你做出那些决定不可思议，然后过上了一种我无法想象的生活，就我做出的决定而言，我把与男人的关系放在首位。你总是把我也带大得非常关注事业，关注教育，而不是关注关系。但那与你在我这个年纪所做的决定完全矛盾。在一定程度上，为了一段关系，你丢弃了以前所有的自己。”
Then she told me something. Something she'd actually been kind of saying to me all along throughout this entire conversation. Whether it was about what she didn't have with Laurence or what she did have with my dad, or with Jimmy.
然后她告诉我一些事情。一些她在这整个谈话中一直暗示我的事情。无论是关于她与劳伦斯没有拥有的，还是她与我父亲拥有的，或者与吉米拥有的。
Relationships were always important to me. As important as career. My mother died when I was your age. And in the time running up to that, the thing that hurt her most, upset her most, was the thought that I didn't have someone.
“关系对我来说一直很重要。和事业一样重要。我母亲在我你这个年纪去世了。在那之前的时间里，最让她伤心、最让她不安的是，我没有伴侣的想法。”
I'm glad this isn't how she raised me. And I want to take a moment to state the obvious here. I'm fully aware that when I questioned her decision to start a family, any criticism might sound completely insane. I wouldn't be here if my mom hadn't made the choices she did.
我很高兴她不是那样抚养我长大的。我想在这里声明显而易见的事实。我完全意识到，当我质疑她组建家庭的决定时，任何批评听起来可能都完全疯狂。如果我妈妈没有做出她的选择，我就不会在这里。
Does it upset you that I'm critical of the decisions you made? And that I'm so kind of black and white about, I would never do that, I'd never give up my job to have four kids and get married and whatever and lead the life that you went on to lead. Does that upset you?
“我对你所做的决定持批评态度让你感到困扰吗？而且我非常非黑即白地认为，我永远不会那样做，我永远不会为了生四个孩子、结婚、无论做什么、过你后来过的生活而放弃我的工作。这让你感到困扰吗？”
No. I'm very glad you wouldn't do what I did because you're-- it's a different time, you're a different person. I expect you to be very critical.
“不。我很高兴你不会做我做过的事，因为你——这是不同的时代，你是不同的人。我期望你非常具有批判性。”
I think you judge me because you're my daughter and you're very judgmental. That's who you are. And I think you're pinning it on to something here. You've got to find a reason for doing it and so you've made it that one. I think the judging comes first and the reason for judging comes after.
“我想你评判我，因为你是我的女儿，而且你非常爱评判人。那是谁。而且我想你把矛头指向了这里。你必须找到一个做的理由，所以你把它变成了那个。我认为评判在前，评判的理由在后。”
Do you honestly think that? Do you honestly think that? That it's just that I'm judgmental and therefore, I'm saying, let me pick a reason to judge her? It's not that I think you could have achieved so much more had you not become a wife and mother?
“你真的这么想吗？你真的这么想吗？仅仅是因为我爱评判，所以我说，让我找个理由来评判她？并不是我认为如果你没有成为妻子和母亲，你可以取得更多成就吗？”
But I don't think I could because I think being a wife and mother stabilized me in ways that-- I was very, very up and down and insecure in the midst of all this. But becoming, not so much a wife, but a mother really grounded me and, in many ways, made me much more confident. So no, for me, those were the right decisions and I think you're wrong to judge me on that.
“但我认为我做不到，因为我认为成为妻子和母亲在某种程度上稳定了我——我在所有这一切中非常非常起伏不定且缺乏安全感。但成为，与其说是妻子，不如说是母亲，真正让我扎根，在许多方面让我变得更加自信。所以不，对我来说，那些是正确的决定，我认为你以此评判我是错误的。”
If I came home one day and said to you, I'm marrying someone and I'm going to essentially put my career on hold slash quit my career, would you be happy with that?
“如果有一天我回家告诉你，我要嫁给某人，并且我基本上要搁置我的事业或者退出我的事业，你会为此感到高兴吗？”
I'd be very, very, very upset. I think what you're muddling up is judging and wanting to follow in my footsteps. And I hope you won't follow in my footsteps.
“我会非常非常非常不安。我想你混淆了评判和想要追随我的脚步。我希望你不要跟随我的脚步。”
Because you'd judge me. You would judge me if I followed in your footsteps. That's why, right? That's you being judgmental of me, too.
“因为你会评判我。如果你追随你的脚步，你会评判我。那就是为什么，对吧？这也是你在评判我。”
No, it's not. It's because I know you. Well, and my mother used to say, I know you, Katherine. And I'd say, no, you don't. But actually, she did. And I know you and I know if you followed in my footsteps, I'd think some kind of spirit had possessed you.
“不，不是。是因为我了解你。嗯，我母亲过去常说，我了解你，凯瑟琳。我会说，不，你不了解。但其实，她了解。我了解你，而且我知道如果你跟随我的脚步，我会认为有什么样的灵魂附身在你身上了。”
There's something comforting in knowing she gets me, even if I can't always return the favor. Listening back, I hear how judgy I am. I get that she made the decisions that were right for her, just not for me. And that's OK. Perhaps that's just the trick of parenting. You can't always lead by example.
知道她理解我，有一种安慰感，即使我不能总是回报这种恩情。重听录音，我听到自己是多么爱评判。我明白她做出了对她而言正确的决定，只是不适合我。这没关系。也许这就是为人父母的技巧。你不能总是以身作则。
Reya El-Salahi. She's a reporter and anchor for the London TV channel, London Live.
雷亚·埃尔-萨拉希。她是伦敦电视频道“伦敦直播”的记者和主播。
[MUSIC - "REBEL WITHOUT A PAUSE" BY PUBLIC ENEMY]
[音乐 - “叛逆无需停歇” by 公共敌对乐队]
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and Karen Duffin. Our staff includes Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Jonathan Menjivar, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Music help today from Damien Graef.
嗯，我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩和凯伦·达芬制作。我们的员工包括苏珊·伯顿、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·傅、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、克里斯托弗·斯维塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。今天的音乐支持来自达米恩·格拉夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, at my niece's birthday party last weekend. I asked him to teach everybody to play musical chairs. And I don't know, he got really intense about it.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播电台通过PRX公共广播交易所播出。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，上周末在我侄女的生日聚会上。我请他教大家玩抢椅子游戏。我不知道，他对那个游戏变得非常紧张。
When I say stand, lift your ass off the seat and keep it in the air until I tell you to sit.
“我说站起来时，把屁股从座位上抬起来，一直保持在空中，直到我叫你坐下。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "I DON'T WANT NOBODY TO GIVE ME NOTHING (OPEN UP THE DOOR I'll GET IT MYSELF)" BY JAMES BROWN]
[音乐 - “我不想要任何人给我任何东西（打开门我自己去拿）” by 詹姆斯·布朗]